so listening to Diego was fascinating
because for two reasons one is I only
came into this kind of business a couple
of years ago so until two years ago I
Bree had no idea I would never have
understood anything that he was talking
about or indeed what I'm going to talk
about and I think if I had known what I
was talking about then honestly I might
have done what he's doing and not what
I'm doing I'm very much working within
the system that's how i came into it
there are advantages to that but it's
it's really exciting to see the things
that are kind of coming up from the
periphery that i'm unable and if I like
my job to be involved in but I think
when I when I talk about what I'm doing
which is with it very much within the
system in a very specific narrow
targeted area you'll be able to see
maybe what I think in if anything it'll
highlight the positive aspects of what
you're doing so just to talk a little
bit about where I come from I as i said
i'm new to the energy world before this
I i worked in international development
for many years and then I did my PhD and
social anthropology here at Yale
graduating 2010 and after graduating and
I taught I adopted for a year or so and
I took the plunge to leave academia
partly for personal reasons my husband's
a full-time professor the idea of
looking for a full-time job made me want
to weep but I also was a South Asian
'used and I'd been living in new haven
for 10 years and really wanted to work
in and around and about New Haven so I
decided to move into the into the
nonprofit sector and at the time I felt
like I was my PhD had kind of been a
waste and I was just starting an
entirely new career that wasn't relevant
but it's actually been really fulfilling
to realize that what I learned
academically has actually been very
useful in when I'm trying to do more
practical applied to work so I've been
the coordinator of the L community
carbon front for almost two years it's a
part-time position 20 hours in yells
Office of Sustainability the Yale office
of sustainability is primary goal
is to increase sustainability on campus
as I said making every building on
campus like this in an ideal world they
also are interested in kind of global
connections between Yale and other
academic institutions overseas but it's
kind of Yale and it's the world and
there's not really much attention
Frankie no attention paid to New Haven
the position that I have is the one
position in the office that actually
looks outside Yale's campus to New Haven
briefly a history of the L community
carbon fund it was set up in 2009 as it
came out of a joint somf forestry school
class the idea was that Yale as an
institution would as part of its carbon
emissions reduction strategy purchase
offsets the money it would buy the
offsets through putting money in a local
fund which would be invested in local
energy efficiency or renewable energy
projects that also benefited low-income
people and the carbon credits could be
taken by Yale and used towards its its
emissions goal emissions reductions goal
as it happens Yale decided not to
include offsets in its strategy which
may be a good thing I'm not sure about
that and we we spent quite a lot of time
trying to generate individual and
departmental offset purchases by getting
people who are organizing events to
calculate how many missions they were
producing and donate to the fund it's
very labor-intensive to try and raise
that kind of money and you get very
irregular and unpredictable in small
amounts of money so officially that
still how the fund works that people
purchase offsets we have a fund that we
then invest in energy efficiency and
renewable energy stuff in New Haven
frankly speaking it doesn't really work
most of our funding is from private
foundations who were interested in this
idea and have made donations to the fund
and the current project that it that I'm
running and that was already existing
when I got the job was low-income
insulation now even though the offsets
model piece had kind of you know wasn't
really working it still seemed like kind
of like a no-brainer we had 150 thousand
dollars to invest in to put insulation
in the houses of low income people in
New Haven it seemed
like honestly to me and when I got this
job I was like great 20 hours a week
Yale health insurance doing something
that's there's a need super easy to do I
can find do some other stuff on the side
and I learned pretty quickly that it
wasn't easy at all in fact it was really
hard so it became a few months when I
first started it became apparent but so
this is an uninsulated ethic this is the
problems of having an uninsulated ethic
and this is putting insulation it became
apparent that although there's a clear
need and we have money putting those two
things together didn't necessarily solve
the problem so rather than just work
just giving spending this money my job
has become much more about trying to
understand why we can't spend that money
effectively and just as a to kind of
frame it a little bit I came to this job
thinking okay I have spent a hundred
fifty thousand dollars or whatever was
on insulation in low-income homes it
turns out that there is an existing
program just like ma saves it's called
the Home Energy Solutions Program a
statewide program funded by the rapier
will pay on our electricity and gas
bills and if you're low income and it's
a generous definition of low income as
I'll show you you have to be owning
sixty percent of the state median income
or below those services are completely
free so there was actually kind of a ton
of money already out there for this
stuff so I'm thinking hang on a minute a
is this really additional and B if
there's already a ton of money out there
for their stuff why is it that there are
still so many people who haven't had
their needs met so again it just kind of
confirmed that the problem wasn't money
the problem was understanding how to
spend that money effectively so I'll
just try and explain briefly why it's
been difficult for me to spend my money
in a good way and and what we what I've
been trying to do about it so you know
unsurprisingly the fundamental for the
fundamental situation and actually the
fundamental problem is poverty New Haven
is an extremely poor city I lived here
for 10 years and I knew it was poor it
wasn't until I actually started studying
New Haven as a
practitioner not i can and academic that
I really began to appreciate just how
poor New Haven is twenty-six percent of
people live below the poverty line that
is twenty three thousand dollars a year
for a family of four or 11,000 also for
one person the reason I put all these
numbers are that is because honestly
I've been trying to work this out for
myself for years there are so many
different levels different definitions
of poverty and different levels at which
you qualify for different things so if
you're interested here it is it was
mostly just for me the point of all this
is so if you want to have fuel
assistance which is help paying your oil
bill you have to be at one hundred and
fifty percent of the poverty level 35 or
so for a family of four to qualify for
free energy assistance which is the
program that I actually partner with run
by the utility united illuminating and
it's siu which is Home Energy Solutions
income eligible you need to be at this
level 61 around 74 62,000 for a family
of four the reason it's worth
understanding all these numbers is
really two things one twenty-six percent
of people in New Haven live at almost a
third of the level at which you qualify
for free energy assistance free energy
efficiency assistance that tells you how
many people in this city qualify for the
free service and it's not arbitrary
there has been research to show that if
you're at this level two hundred percent
of the federal poverty level which is
roughly similar to this a little lower
there is an average annual shortfall in
Connecticut for you able to pay your
energy costs of two thousand three
hundred dollars or so so that means the
need is dire there are likely fifty
percent or more of people in New Haven
who cannot afford to pay their energy
bills and who need assistance in some in
some way so obviously if you can make
their homes use less energy you're not
just helping them you're helping the
taxpayer right you're hoping to be more
comfortable you know reduce carbon
emissions it's then there's no doubt
that the need is there so the need is
there I have money the state program has
money what's going on as it turns out
that's actually the problem the problem
is poverty throwing puppet money at
poverty doesn't really work and I'll
just quickly go through some of the
challenges that frankly everyone in the
business kind of knew but there wasn't
anyone really pulling it together not in
Connecticut at least and not in an urban
context so just very briefly the kind of
people we're talking about here can be
difficult to reach out to disabled
people elderly people tend to be
isolated more broadly there's a kind of
lack of trust and understanding between
the type of people promoting these
programs and I very much put myself and
certainly Yale in that category and the
people that we're trying to you know
service this this issue that people who
don't have much money frankly I worried
about other things getting at insulation
in your attic is you know it's really
not at the top of your list of what you
have to be worried about and there's
been some interesting research very
recently which has been widely reported
about how people who are struggling with
poverty in the related immediate needs
actually their brains are unable to do
long term planning it's everyone's brain
would be in that situation so it doesn't
matter to most people frankly because
it's a long term complex issue most of
New Haven most of you hadn't residents
around to seventy percent of people in
the city rent that's higher among the
low-income groups the poorer you are the
light year you are to have a crappy
landlord who doesn't really care so eat
where even if you've got the best
landlord in the world you have this
split incentives problem where the
tenant doesn't have an incentive to
invest in this because they may be
leaving anyway the landlord doesn't have
an incentive because they probably don't
pay the bills so that's a kind of
fundamental problem that you have trying
to get this work done getting
coordination I mean now what my job has
ended up being is co-ordinating this
process reaching out to people
persuading them to sign up and then
taking them through the process simply
getting a form signed by your landlord
can take seven months a year and if you
are not checked if you're not pushing it
doesn't happen all the documentation you
have to get from the landlord from the
tenants it's even if you own your home
you have to provide a fair amount of
documentation and then just coordination
problem 75% of
housing units in New Haven and
multi-family so if you want to really
deal with that building you have to deal
with everyone who lives in that building
and you know contractors make repeated
visits because they can't line it up so
that everyone's there at the same time
and then you have this fundamental
problem of the fear of discovery of code
violations so this when I first started
this this was kind of seen as a landlord
problem like landlords don't want you to
know that they have crappy housing
conditions so they don't want the energy
audit done in the home as it turns out
tenants you live in cheap housing also
don't want somebody to come and point
out the code violations because then
they get thrown out of the house and if
you if you have a good deal you'd rather
live with the threat of mold you know
ask summer causing mold and that kind of
stuff then be thrown out on the street
not be able to afford to live anywhere
else so nobody wants somebody looking in
their house beat out the tenant or the
landlord so when so that's getting
people even interested in the first
place once you get people signed up
coordination scheduling documentation
the numerous jobs drop out of the system
because even when people have signed up
things go wrong this is a huge barrier
most houses in New Haven have some of
these problems if energy efficiency team
goes to conduct an audit in a home and
they find any of these problems they
can't do the audit it's just it's a lost
job and they may have scheduled 3-4
hours and it's a lost job they can't do
it in theory there are programs to kind
of to help remediate those problems but
it's not just a matter of funding for
remediating those problems it's a matter
of coordinating the process so that it
so that it keeps moving people there is
some money to pay for this stuff for
other things like broken furnaces there
is no money so you would have to pay
yourself or there are some fantastic
subsidized loans out there the
Connecticut housing investment fund has
great loans but if you have bad credit
you can't get the loans and then
ultimately contractors who are
for-profit businesses after all and you
probably even seen this in the work you
do however much your mission maybe to
serve those who are struggling most you
can't make money doing it it's just too
expensive it's too expensive to what to
work with people who
there when you turn up who may leave the
landlords in Florida the house is full
of stuff that you can't you know you
can't spend hours and hours and hours on
a job that ultimately you're not going
to make any money from and plus frankly
a lot of these contractors are scared
they didn't want to go to these
neighborhoods they're like you know they
won't like this when they get out of
their cars it's it's it's but further
the prophet thing is the biggest problem
you can't expect people you know
for-profit companies to do endless
charity work how much time have I got
okay I'll finish quickly so I you know I
have some stories specific stories about
how how that plays out in practice but
very briefly what what what what am i
arguing should be done about this now if
if I wasn't in this job i'll probably be
saying you know let's bring him here and
set up his system here but I'm
constrained by my position within Yale
more than you might think I'm
constrained because of the fact i work
in partnership with the utilities so i'm
looking fairly narrowly what can be done
within the current system one of the
things we argue is that just just money
for these services doesn't meet the need
you have to have money allocated to deal
with the problems that come up along the
way be their health and safety problems
co-ordinating case management so it's
rick arguing kind of a reallocation of
funding and this is something that makes
that i have not been able to do but i
think would be really really really
exciting from a research perspective is
basically advocating for better data
tracking that incorporate socio-economic
data so this is the horrendous map that
is new haven disease income inequality
track overlaying this brilliant data
that's free for everyone from the census
with data from the energy efficiency
work so if you could overlay this with
right where have we had successful
outreach okay we've had successful
outreach where have we been able to
actually complete the jobs and where we
haven't been able to complete the jobs
what has got in the way is it landfill
coordination is it mold is it whatever
it might be because if you could do that
you could really get a strong pic and
then you could also overlap with housing
type right age of housing and you could
read
you get a really solid understanding of
what the what type of problems come from
which type of situation the problem is
is that that data is with the utility
companies so that's a sort of ongoing
conversation about how much data they're
prepared to share and ultimately if you
could even share this with utility data
right high energy users people who are
on the match put matched if you don't
have enough money you can get a matched
payment scheme with the utility to just
get a real sense of how socio-economic
situation overlaps with energy
efficiency and it's not just a you know
a do good cause when you have a city
like this and there are many cities like
this where Madrid majority of the
population falls into this hard to reach
category if you want to meet your
targets you have to understand how to
reach out to this population so I'll
finish up with just kind of coming back
to me as an academic and me and this
work so as I said I realized fairly soon
after entering this job that my academic
training was not in fact irrelevant that
I hadn't wasted ten years even though I
was studying Pakistan I wasn't studying
anything to do with new haven or America
itch I'm actually quite bad at my job
honestly speaking I don't want to do
this long-term because I'm not very good
at it I'm disorganized I forget things I
don't like calling people randomly all
the stuff that you have to do to case
manage and develop partnerships I'm
quite bad at but I do think that my
academic training even without me
realizing it enables me to look at a
specific situation a woman who's
struggling with a broken furnace and
kind of connect it with historical
structural cultural things that have
made that situation happen so what
someone like me can contribute to the to
the debate is kind of a more strategic
vision right people do turn to operate
in silos even in academia and but
someone with academic training can kind
of bring this bigger picture to it and
that's specifically true of
anthropological training I think not
that that's the only useful academic
study one of the things that I found
interesting is that the end
efficiency business has kind of been
taken over in the academic setting by
the behavioral behavioral economics
right that behavioral economics key
seems actually be to be taking over the
world and I actually studied it for a
bit and is brilliant I mean it's
absolutely brilliant to understand how
you can nudge people into making you
know good decisions it's a little bit
weird and sort of big brother-ish but I
think it's also quite brilliant but I it
bothers me because I think however
useful it is and I actually do use it I
don't just read it I think that focus on
behavioural change can really blind us
to these bigger sort of fundamental
structural problems that frankly the
cause of the problem so the people I'm
talking about it doesn't matter how much
you nudge them the choice is that they
should be making simply aren't open to
them so that's you know I really
appreciate the fact that economists have
got into practice you know they can
spread out beyond academia but other
disciplines need to be there with them
again a benefit of having academic
training means that i can speak to
academics i'm kind of culturally
competent you know people take me
seriously because I've got a PhD that is
amazingly useful I had no idea how
useful that would be I've never it
scared because my position is not senior
but people really listen to me and
that's because I have a PhD it doesn't
matter my ph isn't something irrelevant
it gives you a kind of status that you
have to you can use but also having this
job has made me realize that making
something happen is much much much
harder than reading about it talking
about it thinking about it so it's been
very humbling in that sense so it's it's
I don't know if what's the best model
for really being able to translate
academic learning into practice but it's
somehow a combination of taking
advantage of the status you have but
also wrecking ball about how limited you
are and I'll stop there
you